you've had this unique and wonderful
experience where you've pretty much been
able to meet I would think everybody at
this point everyone's come to see the
play is there anybody who you've met
where you were completely freaked out
where you thought like oh my god I've
always wanted to meet this person here
they are in the flesh and it kind of
yeah ooh your mind though the most
severe one of those actually happened
pre Hamilton it was the first time I met
Weird Al Yankovic I keep in mind you
have met presidents now you've met
everybody have met every single
celebrity and I actually I liked your
choice Weird Al that was that was tough
it was um he had just I think I try to
remember the pretense for the meeting he
had just signed with our agency and they
said he's looking to meet with people to
talk about a musical and I would me and
so they arranged for me to go meet him
at his house and I have no chill
whatsoever I answered the door himself
he said hey nice to meet you he's the
nicest guy in the world
and I said hey nice to meet you I really
love your house I know you studied
architecture as an undergrad did you
design it
imagine you were on a date and that was
like the thing it was one of those
things we're like and he was very sweet
and we talked for a little while we had
a little food then I went home and I was
so upset with my own behavior that I
went home and took a nap like a child
like Ramon you were little and you were
so sad that like only a nap would fix it
that's how I felt like embarrassing
myself in front of Weird Al Yankovic
you